[Musique]
bienvenue quel plaisir de vous retrouver
cette rentrée se fait sous le soleil et
sous le signe de l'innovation
paris-saclay tv vous fait découvrir l'un
des fleurons du territoire nous sommes à
air liquide
air liquide qui a choisi paris saclay
pour installer son plus grand centre de
développement et de recherche
le site vient tout juste d'être inauguré
ici plus de 350 chercheurs travaillent
sont répartis dans 48 laboratoire il ya
aussi des plateformes pilote quels sont
les enjeux qui accompagne ce nouvel
équipement
réponse dans un instant air liquide est
leader dans son domaine mais paris
saclay ce sont aussi des start up
elles ont des idées mais pas toujours
les moyens pourquoi ne pas leur donner
un petit coup de pouce financier via
synapses vous saurez tout de cette
nouvelle plateforme de financement
connaissez-vous nous in saclay ce
programme veut mettre un coup
d'accélérateur pour assurer une
meilleure mobilité sur le territoire
comment faire mieux comment innover
le pea paris saclay qui l'un des grands
acteurs de ce programme a participé à la
session d'accélération organisé en
septembre
nous y étions enfin notre agenda c'est
un rendez vous incontournable et bien
sûr ce sera à la fin de cette émission
[Musique]
nous voici au coeur du plus grand centre
de recherche d'air liquide le leader
mondial des gaz technologies et services
pour l'industrie et la santé a fait le
pari de s'implanter à paris saclay il y
à 70 ans un pari réussi
ce bâtiment à haute performance
énergétique accueille plus de 350
chercheurs
on y trouve 48 laboratoires qui sont
dotées de matériel de pointe
il y a aussi des plateformes
expérimentales ce campus d'innovation
accueillera même dès 2019 un
accélérateur de start up dit tech nous
avons assisté à l'inauguration
[Musique]
il
aujourd'hui c'est un jour important pour
liquides
parce que nuzzolo goron un campus
d'innovation avec un centre de recherche
que l'on voit aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi l'innovation est
importante pour nous parce qu'on a
toujours compris que la différenciation
du groupe était d'être capable d'innover
en permanence et ceci depuis plus d'un
siècle
alors cap lors nous innovation la
capacité que nous avons à traduire notre
connaissance scientifique sur des
petites molécules essentielles jusqu'à
la mise sur le marché et pour faire ce
long voyage de la science business comme
on dit il faut être capable d'animer
tout un écosystème des académiques des
technologues des business et la mise en
opération et nous avons conçu ce centre
pour être accueillants pour être ouverts
pour permettre à cet écosystème très
large d'exister entre des chercheurs
entre des personnes qui développent les
applications et qui les mettent sur le
marché et à la fin des clients et le
tout proche de ce qu'on appelle les
académiques sur ceux qui ont la capacité
à nous ouvrir encore plus loin vers la
science
quand on 70 je remonte loin en 70 on a
mis ce centre de recherche
ici tout le monde disait c'est rodin de
paris regardez 48 ans après paris sacre
est arrivé c'est une formidable
opportunité pour nous parce que quelque
part on voit arriver ici des universités
des grandes entreprises une notoriété
internationale
donc c'est une divine surprise alors
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons reformé heureux remis au goût
du jour je dirais 60 de recherche et ce
campus d'innovation
parce que nous voulions être je dirais
en synchronisation parfaite avec 7
ce cluster encore une fois d'une
réputation internationale à des diables
l'innovation ouverte l'écosystème il
faut le faire vivre
il faut avoir des alliances j'en ai
plusieurs en tête qui assistait mme x il
ya peu ps qui à la fabrication additive
on regarde donc à chaque fois qu'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire
on essaye de mettre des clients des
partenaires des universités ensemble et
on essaie de créer un écosystème
réserver assez assez assez initiative
est donc on voit apparaître
effectivement toute une série de micro
écosystèmes à l'intérieur de ce vaste
écosystème qu'est paris saclay
[Musique]
et si tout le monde pouvait donner un
petit coup de pouce financier aux
entreprises du territoire
c'est ce que propose synapses cette
plateforme de financement original est
tournée vers le grand public pour que
chacun chacune puisse financer des start
up mais pas seulement
alors comment ça marche et pour quel
résultat écoutez nathalie ricoeur
nicolet cofondatrice de scientifiques
capitale
[Musique]
ce soir nous avons inauguré la
plateforme de financement synapses qui
est une plateforme territoriale de
financement dédié aux territoires paris
saclay alors pourquoi territoriales
parce que c'est d'abord ça nous permet
de nous habitants mesure sage et du
territoire de financer en ligne à
travers un prêt ou un investissement des
entreprises qui ont un lien avec avec
paris saclay territoriale aussi parce
qu'elle repose sur un partenariat de
l'ensemble des acteurs du territoire qui
sont engagés dans la recherche dans
l'innovation dans l'accompagnement des
entreprises la création d'entreprise et
dans le financement et qui aident senti
peu le capital qui est à l'initiative de
ce projet à constituer une communauté de
financeurs à instruire les projets à les
suivre à les accompagner pour en faire
vivre cette plateforme est enfin
territoriales parce qu'elle a pour
ambition d'être la vitrine technologique
de toute la technologie développée sur
le territoire de paris saclay qui comme
on le sait une technologie haut de gamme
avec une forte portée internationale
[Musique]
ce qu'on espère c'est que les
technologies développées dans les tec
c'est à dire des technologies profondes
avec des phases de r&d longue attirant
bientôt les investisseurs internationaux
et que la plateforme synapses sera le
lieu où les startups deep tech en
recherche de financement pourront être
présentées et financer
[Musique]
améliorer la mobilité sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est la mission de move in
saclay ce programme est plutôt récent
mais il ya déjà beaucoup d'idées
beaucoup de projets pour rendre les
transports plus performant plus efficace
pour une saclay a profité de la semaine
européenne des mobilités pour accélérer
le mouvement
les explications de ghislain delaby
connecteurs mobilité ou cher il va nous
donner des exemples très concrets
[Musique]
ou virak l'est déjà c'est un programme
qui depuis six mois et qui permet des
acteurs publics et privés de
paris-saclay de travailler ensemble en
vue d' innover au service du territoire
pour une meilleure mobilité des
transports plus performant plus
qualitatif
aujourd'hui c'est la première journée de
la semaine européenne de la mobilité
on a choisi cette journée pour avoir une
journée d' accélération du programme
c'est à dire on a déjà beaucoup dit et
est maintenant il s'agit de passer à
l'action de faire en sorte qu'ils
deviennent concrètes des projets qui
puissent être des foyers dans les
prochains mois produire des résultats
qu'on puisse évaluer qu'on puisse aussi
financé et puis qu'on s'organise entre
un nombre important de partenaires nous
avons une quarantaine de partenaires
publics et privés on a des start up on a
des industriels on a les trois
agglomérations paris saclay versailles
grand parc saint quentin en yvelines on
a le père paris saclay qui se plie de le
développer le plateau de saclay et tous
les projets immobiliers et puis on a de
nombreux acteurs industriels du
territoire qui travaillent dans les
transports dans l'intelligence
artificielle dans la mobilité et c sont
tous des acteurs qui ont travaillé
ensemble ce matin qui ont avancé sur des
plans projets concrets avec des
résultats à la clé pour 2019
et puis cette après midi on a fait un
focus plus globale sur des projets qui
sont déjà existants des projets qui sont
déjà opérationnels on a parlé de
stationnement mutualisé par exemple avec
nous avec nous volent sur le plateau de
saclay des mois prochain et bien il y
aura des possibilités de stationner dans
des parkings privés ouverts au public
pour l'occasion avec une seule appli en
toute simplicité
on a aussi parlé de d'hydrogène à
versailles avec des bornes hydrogène qui
sont disponibles désormais des
expérimentations de bus et de vélos
cargo on a parlé d' information
voyageurs avec viagogo à saint quentin
en yvelines c'est un projet qui permet
d'avoir encore plus d'informations quand
on fait un itinéraire à saint quentin en
yvelines et et bientôt sur l'ensemble du
territoire de paris secret et enfin on
n'a pas réussi de coworking c'est à dire
de bureaux partagés disponible pour
quelques heures
et c'est un sujet important parce que
quand on met d'un bureau partagé et des
salles de réunion à côté d'une gare de
massy-palaiseau c'est le 30 et 20 avec
ce projet là on permet à des gens qui
viennent de différents endroits de se
retrouver facilement vous permet aussi à
beaucoup de personnes de travailler au
plus proche de chez elle et de limiter
leurs déplacements de garder les
meilleurs déplacements et de supprimer
les déplacements les plus contraignants
finalement au quotidien et ce soir on
termine par une dimension plus
prospective avec des intervenants très
divers de l'argument de la recherche des
zébus pour nous parler de comment des
territoires peuvent innover dans la
mobilité
quels sont les défis associés qu'est ce
qu'on peut en attendre réellement et aux
sciences et aux détache un petit peu du
buzz médiatique
et maintenant comme promis l'agenda il
ya beaucoup de rendez vous en cette
rentrée avec déjà la fête de la science
organisée par la communauté
d'agglomération paris saclay expositions
spectacles ateliers y en a vraiment pour
tous les goûts c'est du 1er au 31
octobre
l'agenda est disponible sur paris saclay
points comme le 10 octobre 2018 c'est le
go to start up tour paris saclay vous
êtes étudiant vous rêvez de start up et
bien venez rencontrer de jeunes
entrepreneurs
c'est à l'université d'evry de 18h30 à
21h bâtiment ile de france c'est au
premier étage salle 106 1 le 23 octobre
il sera question d'éthique et de
déontologie avec une rencontre inédite
intégrité scientifique
quelle stratégie nationale face aux
enjeux contemporains les signataires de
la charte nationale de déontologie des
métiers de recherche et répondront c'est
à l'office crs de rue albert einstein
dans le xiiie enfin n'oublions pas les
grands rendez vous culturels de votre
territoire
c'est l'une des plus grandes voix
malienne où sont garés sera en concert
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est le samedi 13 octobre à 20h30
enfin ramsès ii est une pièce truffé de
chausse trappes qui réjouit le public ne
ratez pas françois berléand et eric
elmosnino
ils seront à l'opéra de massy à partir
du 16 octobre à 20h pour cette
excellente pièce je vous rappelle le
titre
ramsès de paris saclay tv c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui merci de votre
attention on se retrouve très vite et
d'ici là restez informé sur tv 78 et sur
notre site pap.fr a très vite
[Musique]